I have to say I'm a human more recently
I think people think because you get a
lofty title and you're the CEO that you
stop being a human I decided
about a year ago that I needed my life
back and as much as you can trade
everything for money and for guts and
glory and taking a business and a vision
and a dream if I'm not healthy enough to
be the the head of the table and not not
healthy enough to take that place then
it's not all going to be for nothing and
so I was just sad with how alert how I
felt where I was at I was giving my soul
to a business that was giving it back to
me and the people in it gave it back to
me but I wasn't giving any love to
myself
and so I had to had to get consistency
in my my routine in my food in my gym
and buy some time back uh what people
wouldn't know is at the same time as
going uh and losing all that weight I
also worked abroad every month for a
week really to take a bit of life back
so I spent a week in Barcelona I spent a
week in Italy France I was all over the
all over the globe
um buying my time back and looking
outside into the business working just
as hard and nothing slept if anything I
worked harder Max will remember the week
I was in Barcelona just grafting and it
was harder work than if I was sat in my
office in Bristol and I was like I don't
really know what we're doing and I I
decided that things that I do that I can
enjoy and the business would be a
vehicle for that is okay it doesn't have
to be work 14 15 hours a day it doesn't
have to be takeaway every night it
doesn't have to be like lunch at your
desk you could buy a time back with
investment and I invested in myself and
I'm now a happier person I am a human
um and I think people do well to
remember we're all just people be kind
to yourselves to your colleagues to
everyone the recruitment mentors podcast
is proudly sponsored by VIN cherry and
the award-winning Source breaker
[Music]